معنا بروفيسور في جامعه الملك سعود
استشاري قصرت الشرايين والصمامات الدكتور
محمد البارقي دكتور محمد مساء الخير حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض خلينا
نعرف اولا لماذا لا تزال نصب النسب
الاصابه بالسكري في السعوديه
مرتفعه جدا مقارنه بالمعدلات المتوسطه
عالميا
اول شيء شكرا على الاستضافه بالنسبه لنسبه
السكري في المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
اعلى نسب في دول العالم يعني عندنا في كل
في كل مئه شخص 29 الى 30 شخص منهم صعب
بالسكري ونسبه ثانيه نسميهم بريده يعني
للاسف مهيئين انه يصابوا بامراض السكر
المجتمع تعرف يعني جات له فتره والى الان
للاسف انه نسبه السكر زايده معها نسبه
السمنه زائده الحركه قليله فهذه الاشياء
بالاضافه الى العوامل الوراثيه والجينيه
في اغلب العوائل للاسف في المملكه
بما فيها عوائل الاطباء فيهم مرض السكر
دكتور الان امراض القلب في السعوديه تصيب
الاشخاص كما ذكرت بشكل
ابكر جدا من من الدول الاخرى بما يصل الى
نحو عشره اعوام لماذا السعوديه لديها يعني
هذا هذا الامر ايش المسببات ايضا
وهل بامكان
وهل بامكاننا مثلا ان نقلص مثلا هذه
الفتره تصبح بدايه المعدلات العالميه
هنا للاسف في دراسات علميه سويناها في
المملكه وشركت فيها عده مراكز طبيه اثبتت
ان الاصابه بجلطات القلب والذبحه الصدريه
في مواطنين المملكه العربيه السعوديه ابدر
بعشر سنوات من المعدل العام في العالم
وهذا يعني نوع هذا الشيء الى ارتفاع نسبه
السكر في مرضانه الان لما نسوي قسطره لكل
100 شخص يعمل قسطره القلب شوف الشرايين
التاجيه ونكشف عليها 65 الى 70% من مردان
السعوديين اللي يخضعون لعمليات القسطره
مصابين بالسكر من الدرجه الثانيه وهذه
اعلى نسبه عالميه لما نقارنها بنسبه
العالم الاخر السكر عندها من 18 الى 30%
والدكتور حاسب الدراسات عندما تتحدثون
بانه ابكر بعشره اعوام هل في معدل اعمار
انتم هي النسبه الاعلى في الاصابه
بتصلب الشرايين او الذبحه الصدريه ايضا
كما ذكرت ولمرتبطه ايضا كذلك بامراض
السكري
لا ننسى انه مريض السكر مهيا ليكون
الكوليسترول عنده مرتفع يكون عنده لا سماح
الله ارتفاع كذلك في الضغط الدم
السمنه للاسف زي ما قلنا مفرطه عدم الحركه
الان الحمد لله في وعي الدوله ما بتقصر
يعني وزاره الصحه المستشفيات العسكريه
مستشفيات الجامعه كلها المستشفيات هذه
تحاول تزود الوعي نسميه اويرنس انه في
مشاكل انتبهوا لها تغيير اللايف ستايل كيف
تعد لحياتك كيف تعدل اكلك يعني كل هذه
الاشياء مهمه جدا
نسبه الكوليسترول الوراثي في دول الخليج
من الدراسات حديثه في دول الخليج حنا اكبر
نسبه كوليسترول وراثي في العالم هي دول
الخليج ومنها المملكه ممكن تكون على راسها
في عده عوامل تشتغل مع بعض مش عامل واحد
فقط يعني يا دكتور اليوم احنا
حتى نخفض من معدلات الاصابه بامراض القلب
نحتاج الى الى الى مجتمع يكون يعني معدلات
الاصابه فيه بالسكري منخفضه هل هذا ما
فهمه منك
[موسيقى]
مجتمعي يبغى له يغير الحياه حقته نمط
الحياه يعني نبغى نمشي اكثر نحاول
نحفظ على نحافظ على نوعيه الاكل الوزن عده
اشياء للاسف شديد واحده من الاشياء اللي
تزعلنا انه الدخان للاسف انتشر في جيل
الشباب بين الاولاد والبنات اكثر من اول
بكثير وهذا عامل مهم درجه انه في فتره
الشتاء اغلب الناس اللي يجونا بجلطات
القلب عن طريق الطوارئ وندخلهم قسطره
للاسف ترى اعمارهم اقل من 30 سنه يعني في
ليله واحده سوينا يمكن ثلاثه كلهم اعمارهم
بين الثلاثين والاربعين هذه الاشياء ما
تشوفها بر
دكتور خطوره الاصابه بالسكري وقسطره
شرايين
الشرايين والصمامات ايضا حتى دكتور هل
هناك نسبه معينه
الخطوره موجوده احنا قلنا الخطوره عامه
30% في المجتمع السعودي تزداد مع قله
الحركه تزداد اذا كان السكري موجود في
العائله وعندهم مشاكل قلبيه فهذا الشخص
اللي عنده مشاكل قلبيه في عائله معرض لا
سمح الله انه يصاب هو في نفسه فعشان كذا
التاليه يا دكتور احنا عندنا 30% من
المصابين بامراض السكري في السعوديه هم
بالضروره مصابين او لديهم قسطره للشرايين
ولديهم انسداد في الصمامات
[موسيقى]
عندهم قابليه او قابليه قابليه تصير عندهم
مشاكل اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
الرياض بروفيسور جامعه الملك سعود استشاري
قسطره الشرايين والصمامات الدكتور محمد
البارقي شكرا الدكتور